[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 nous sommes le mercredi 23 février
voici les titres
151 faits de racisme 14 d'homophobie
enregistrant en 2021 rien que sur le
territoire yvelinois préfecture justice
et académies de versailles sonne la
révolte avec ce plan signé hier il donne
un cadre à la lutte contre le racisme
l'antisémitisme et la haine anti lgbt on
vous explique tout dans un instant
objectif 25 % de logements sociaux fixé
par l'état les communes yvelinoise reste
encore malgré tout largement déficitaire
pour leur venir en aide le conseil
départemental a lancé le plan prévention
carence le pecq est la première ville en
bénéficier avec l'inauguration hier
d'une résidence enfin après sa victoire
de samedi dernier aux mureaux la boxeuse
rima ayadi conserve sa ceinture wbc
continental des légers l habitant de
poissy se tournent désormais vers de
nouveaux horizons un titre européen puis
mondial et le rêve paris 2024 elle est
notre invité mais avant de développer
ses titres rappelez vous le 17 janvier
dernier une soixantaine de circassiens
bloqué la route nationale 10 ils
protestaient contre l'arrêté du maire de
trappes interdisant l'installation de
cirque dans la ville finalement après
une autorisation de la préfecture le
cirque nikolaz avatar fait bien étape à
lille de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines jusqu'au 13 mars le reportage
ce matin à trappes de mathilde au front
mercredi 23 février le brouillard est
bien présent et le cirque zavatta fini
de s'installer sur l'île de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines une
installation dans un contexte tendu avec
la ville de trappes le maire étant en
conflit ouvert avec les gens du cirque
et refusant leur venue une soixantaine
de circassiens avait bloqué la nationale
10 le 17 janvier finalement ils ont eu
gain de cause de la préfecture et ont pu
s'installer c'est normal parce qu'on
vient ici depuis huit ans et pour
quelles raisons
on n'aurait plus le droit d'être ici
alors que la loi de notre côté pour le
moment rien n'interdit au cir que de
donner des représentations avec des
animaux non domestiques cependant en
novembre 2000 21 le gouvernement a voté
une loi interdisant l'acquisition et la
reproduction des animaux sauvages d'ici
deux ans et le transport la détention et
les spectacles d'ici 7 ans nés cirque
ont donc jusqu'à 2028 pour s'adapter en
en 2022 donc on doit s'adapter nos
véhicules ont changé on a changé de
toute l'installation de défendre du côté
des quelques habitants interrogés les
avis sont plutôt catégorique pour moi à
partir du moment où le maire de trappes
a décidé que du coup il n'y avait pas de
cirque à trappes parce qu'il y avait des
animaux sauvages donc je pense que s'il
a évoqué c'est qu'il a laissé ses
raisons et
d'aller à son encontre je trouve pas ça
terrible sauvage je suis assez faim je
suis contre perm ans je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il essaye de s'adapter à
ça moi je suis plutôt pas partie cirque
mais je sais pas un milieu qui me qui me
fascine qui me plaisent vraiment
j'ai toujours un peu de peine de voir
des animaux un peu contraint sur la
piste mais le directeur du cirque la
firme les animaux ne sont pas maltraités
aux animaux sont de bonnes conditions
les vétérinaires vienne vienne les
soigner vient de s'en occuper les
animaux font partie de notre culture et
ils grandissent avec nous ils
vieillissent avec nous c'est une culture
le chercher existe depuis plus de 250
ans maintenant pourquoi on enlèverait
nos cultures le cirque zavatta se
tiendra sur l'île de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines du 23 février au 13
mars des spectacles auront lieu tous les
jours à 16 heures et les dimanches à 15h
mélanie pocket avec mon plateau bonsoir
de la rédaction de tv 78 de donner un
cadre à la lutte contre le racisme
l'antisémitisme et la haine anti lgbt je
vous en parlais dans les titres ce mardi
22 février un plan a été signé pour
améliorer la prise en compte de ses
actes quelques chiffres vous avez donné
151 faits de racisme et antisémitisme
ont été relevés par les forces de
sécurité pour l'année 2000 21 dans le
département quatorze d'homophobie
plusieurs acteurs donc son signataire du
plan il ya la préfecture des yvelines
ministère de la justice et les services
départementaux de l'académie de
versailles il se déroulera jusqu'en 2025
autour de quatre axes les explications
de raphaël sodini préfet délégué à
l'égalité des chances un plan sur trois
ans qui fixe 22 actions 22 priorité pour
mieux identifier mieux éduquer mieux
informés et puis aussi mieux réprimer
sur ces phénomènes de haine antisémite
raciste et homophobe mieux informer
mieux sensibiliser la préfecture
souhaite notamment s'appuyer sur ses 9
sites et éducatif qui sont présentes
dans le département et là aussi mélanie
l'éducation nationale va avoir son rôle
à jouer l'académie de versailles note
une recrudescence des propos homophobes
dans les cours d'écoles lors des actions
vont être mises en place dans les
établissements scolaires du département
et ce dès la maternelle bien sûr vous
vous en doutez on va adapter le contenu
et les mots 10 et en fonction du public
il y aura aussi des jeux et des concours
qui seront proposées comme une formation
des professionnels les réseaux sociaux
ont donné en donner une portée virale en
fait à des propos qui avancent qu'il
mettait au cours d'école et puis et puis
on sait les réseaux sociaux si on
donnait malheureusement la possibilité à
des gens peu courageux de se cacher
derrière un pseudonyme et donc ça ça
existe chez chez toutes les personnes y
compris chez les enfants et les
adolescents bien évidemment donc il faut
qu'on travaille vraiment beaucoup
beaucoup sur la question des réseaux
sociaux avec les enfants et aussi avec
les parents et pour les actes déjà comme
il reste la répression ça ce seront les
missions du ministère de la justice si
c'est la volonté d'avoir un regard plus
globale derrière un faits de vol par
exemple parquet souhaite prendre en
compte tout ce qui est fait ou qui est
dit c'est à dire contextualiser et
prendre en compte les circonstances
aggravantes même derrière la répression
la justice doit favoriser l'éducation
par l'organisation notamment de stage de
citoyenneté qui peuvent mettre sur la
thématique du racisme vu globalement les
personnes condamnées en situation d'être
par exemple orienter vers des structures
telles que le mémorial de la shoah ce
qu'on fait déjà et puis dans un avenir
assez proche qu'on espère c'est plutôt
un lieu de mémoire locale qui est la
maison zola et musée dreyfus est une
chose très important dans cette
thématique s'est libéré la parole pour
mieux accompagner les personnes qui
s'estiment victimes et oui ce que le
dépôt de plainte est pour le moment
encore une démarche encore peu fait
imaginer entre 2013 et 2018 en moyenne
seulement 5 % des victimes d'injures et
25% des victimes de menaces ou de
violences à caractère raciste ont fait
l'une des marches alors il ya des
associations qui sont partenaires france
victime 78 et notamment à l'origine ne
fiche réflexe pour guider les victimes
est en forme et on va être beaucoup sur
sur des menaces ou des violences grande
partie des violences c'est vraiment
50% finalement de du type de victimes
qu'on va avoir après c'est plus délicat
de vous donner un pourcentage aussi sur
vraiment sur cette thématique là ce que
ça représente mais c'est des choses qui
reviennent quand même malheureusement
régulièrement alors vous pouvez aussi
composer le 39 28 c'est celui de la
plate forme anti discrimination du
défenseur des droits et qui est
joignable du lundi au vendredi de 9h à
18h au prix d'un appel local merci
mélanie pour toutes ces précisions
depuis l'entrée en vigueur de la loi sru
la majorité des villes doit répondre à
un objectif 25 % de logements sociaux le
département des yvelines est le plus
déficitaire en ile de france en la
matière et pour venir en aide aux
communes le département a lancé son plan
prévention carence une aide à la
construction de logements sociaux la
ville du pec et la première sur le
territoire en bénéficier avec
l'inauguration d'une résidence hier
mardi et bixente imérien santis était
bonne et la voix de céline charles 130
logements étudiants transformer en 90
logements sociaux la résidence les lys
de la ville du pecq ce sont 57 studio 23
2 pièces et 10 3 pièces à proximité du
centre ville pour un prix défiant toute
concurrence pour vous donner un ordre
d'idée les premiers prix des studios
soit 1 200 euros les 20 mètres carrés
quant au pack on est plutôt autour de
600 euros les 20 mètres carrés donc oui
et c'est des prix très attractifs dans
un secteur où il ya une forte demande et
oui y'a pas forcément une offre
importante déjà occupé à deux tiers de
sa capacité c'est la première
inauguration du plan prévention carences
mises en place par le département en
2018 un fonds de 10 7 millions d'euros
apportés pour acheter le bien puis le
revendre à des bailleurs les communes
carences et c'est à dire les communes
qui n'ont pas 25 % de logements sociaux
sont pénalisés par l'état elle paie une
amende donc le département aide de deux
façons soit en aidant à la réalisation
d'opérations de logements sociaux avec
des bailleurs on peut comme on va le
faire à bougival à côté d'ici à viroflay
construire aussi en maille réel
solidaire c'est à dire dissocier la
propriété immobilière de la propriété
foncière cette inauguration arrive à
point nommé pour la commune elle
comptabilise maintenant 24 5 % de
logements sociaux et n'a plus à payer
les 55000 euros damende annuel nous
avons été carences et nous n'avions pas
respecté notre obligation triennal on
était déjà à l'époque à 23% donc ça
avait été un peu dur pour nous ce qui
est une opération canal qui n'a pas pu
se faire à l'époque il ya certaines
communes dont la mienne ou vraiment avec
la meilleure volonté du monde on ne peut
pas construire pour des différends
différentes raisons moi je n'ai plus de
réserves foncières je suis en bord de
seine j'ai les coteaux la ville et dans
l'atteinte d'une dernière opération ces
prochains mois une réhabilitation de
8000 m² de bureaux pour remplir
définitivement le contrat envers l'état
et dépasser les 25 % de logements
sociaux
le sport j - 6 avant nice versailles
demi finale de la coupe de france de
football les yvelinois défi les aiglons
à l'alliance rivera de nice coup d'envoi
21h mardi prochain et en attendant ce
match historique la coupe charles simon
le trophée du tournoi faisait étape ce
mercredi dans les yvelines un passage à
buc au magasin intermarché groupe
partenaire de la compétition dans le
cadre de l'opération petit poucet les
maillots de la rencontre ont été remis à
l'entraîneur youssef chibi et aux
joueurs présents pour l'occasion les
supporters ont pu également posé à côté
du trophée pour rappel les amateurs de
versailles pensionnaire de nationale 2
feront face au troisième de ligue 1
trois divisions séparent les deux
équipes écouter ses interviews
recueillies par est nicolas landry et
florian mayer c'est une grosse fierté de
participer à cette épopée avec avec ce
club j'ai quand j'étais jeune déjà c'est
versailles avait déjà eu des petites
des petites des petites épopée pardon il
avait joué contre dijon etc j'avais même
été ramasseur de balle à air et ouais du
coup c'est une grosse fierté de pouvoir
être acteur de cette édition d'aller
aussi loin et de battre les records du
club c'est une grosse fierté mort
progressivement la parenthèse enchantée
de la coupe de france on a une petite
semaine pour préparer cette rencontre et
aujourd'hui les joueurs travaillent on a
cette possibilité d'être dévalorisés
d'être mis en avant par intermarché en
tant que petit poucet
donc c'est un vrai plaisir de ressentir
cet engouement autour de nous le
programme basse et entraînement
entraînements et ensuite on aura le
déplacement en avion et voilà on va
préparer le match tranquillement et on
va faire au mieux et nice versailles
demi finale de la coupe de france de
football c'est mardi prochain coup
d'envoi à 21h
[Musique]
on vous en parlait lundi sur tv 78 le
club de boxe bam l'héritage organisé son
troisième gala aux mureaux c'était
samedi dernier une soirée qui a permis
entre autres à rim ayadi de conserver sa
ceinture wbc continental des légers rima
qui est avec nous bonsoir
war merci d'être avec nous on va revenir
dans un instant justement sur ce match
parlait aussi de vos prochains objectifs
mais j'accueille aussi et miquel et demi
d'euro bonds sans lesquels journalistes
de la rédaction de tv soixante dix huit
journalistes sport pour mettre en
lumière la boxe dans le département des
yvelines 800 licenciés peut-on dire pour
autant que c'est un département de boxer
les yvelines terre de boxe je vous
réponds oui à grégory vous l'avez dit
ils sont plusieurs milliers à être tombé
amoureux de cette discipline un chiffre
en constante augmentation depuis les jo
de rio en 2016 et les six médailles
gagnées à part la france il est
officiellement 12 clubs dans le
département qui pratique la compétition
à haut niveau à cela il faut ajouter des
dizaines de microstructures on peut
tester à la boxe comme les salles de
fitness ou deux remise en forme parmi
les structures les plus connus j'en ai
retenu trois il ya tout d'abord le club
historique le boxing club de saint
quentin en yvelines avec la team
farrugia et long cours la structure a
été créée en 1999 par antoine farruggia
après son décès c'est son fils tanguy
qui a repris le flambeau en 2014 ils ont
sorti des champions comme biseau bouzid
ou khalid rahilou aujourd'hui il
continue à fabriquer des champions chez
les amateurs ou les professionnels dans
leur petite salle du palais des sports
des encours à saint quentin en yvelines
il est aussi le boxing club de la vieja
qui propose notamment de la boxe
éducative la structure a été fondée en
1992 il ya plus de 150 adhérents ils ont
lancé des jeunes comme l'ancien champion
de france ahmed el moussaoui et il
arrive à hisser régulièrement des
sportifs aux places d'honneur des
championnats de france chez les jeunes
enfin il y à hammam l'héritage un club
de boxe anglaise qui a été créée en mai
à 2016 sur la commune des mureaux le
club a reçu successivement 2017 2018 et
2019 le titre de meilleur club de boxe
anglaise de france il ya plusieurs
champions qui sont sortis de la
structure et le club organise des
combats de boxe sur la commune des
mureaux comme vous pouvez le voir sur
ces images alors ça c'est pour les clubs
michael est ce qu'il ya des champions
des noms de boxeurs qui sont issus des
yvelines alors il y en a des dizaines je
vais pas pouvoir tous les citer à
aujourd'hui quand on y comptera à part
le temps évidemment je vous ai
sélectionné le top 5 mon top 5 c'est
donc le plus médiatique en numéro 1 le
plus médiatique tony hawk à champions
olympiques en 2016 des super lourds il a
commencé la boxe à 6 ans avec son père à
chanteloup-les-vignes il ensuite fait de
la boxe au mur ou jusqu'à ses 16 ans le
sportif de 29 ans est actuellement chez
les professionnels il a un bilan de 11
victoires dont 9 par ko et il vise un
titre mondial dans les prochaines années
a dit là vous m'a dit le boxeur fait
partie de la team farrugia à elancourt
il a remporté le titre européen des
super moyens le sommet d'une carrière
débutée en 2008 il a un bilan de 23
victoires dont 16 par ko pour 5 défaites
et un nul il va avoir 40 2 en août et il
paraît peu probable qui remonte sur le
ring un autre pensionnaire de la team
farruggia rayonner sur la scène
française et européenne marvin petit
alias le gitan c'est son surnom il a
débuté sa carrière en 2009 il a remporté
25 combats chez les professionnels dont
une ceinture ebu européenne il est
aujourd'hui de retour sur le ring avec
son coach chutant guy farrugia pour
tenter de remporter un titre de champion
du monde
rima ayadi qui est avec nous la sportive
est actuellement dans la structure à bam
l'héritage libéraux et elle vient de
conserver son titre de championne wb à
continental aux mureaux ce samedi 19
février et comment parler des boxeurs
évinois sans parler de maiva hamadouche
la boxeuse de 32 ans qui est surnommé el
veneno s'est entraîné avec la team
farrugia est en cours pour préparer les
jeux olympiques de tokyo à l'été dernier
elle s'est inclinée en 16e de finale
aller depuis reparti à l'étranger pour
s'entraîner vous l'aurez compris à
grégory les emmys sont vraiment une
terre de boxe on l'a vu dans cette
chronique oui une petite réaction
d'ailleurs rythme on a l'impression que
c'est un département où il ya une vraie
concentration de gros clubs de vrais
champions aussi dans ce département des
yvelines
oui c'est vrai je ne serai pas vous dire
pourquoi pas ce que
je serais pas vouloir pourquoi il ya
autant de haut niveau dans le spleen en
tout cas pour ma part je peux vous dire
que dans mon club les entraîneurs sont
très réputés donc les gens n'ont pas de
problème à faire la route moi je venais
de paris pour venir m'entraîner homebrew
parce que c'est des entraîneurs qui sont
très réputés bon bah je pense que c'est
la même chose pourtant qui farruggia
maiva hamadouche n'est pas une
yvelinoise de base mais quand on est
motivé ça nous dérange pas d'aller chez
les meilleurs et les meilleurs en
sondant les huiles oui vous parliez de
votre club et de vos entraîneurs les
frères and up c'est eux qui vous ont
attiré dans cette structure bam héritage
on le rappelle vous l'avait rejoint en
décembre 2010 note pourquoi justement de
paris et vous venu dans ce club des
mureaux
lorsque j'ai décidé de passer
professionnel donc auparavant j'étais
dans un club dans le 93 puis j'ai décidé
de passer professionnel est le meilleur
club il m'est rentré mendés france donc
en boxe professionnelle
s'ils sont avisés abadila à la basse et
ils ont été élus coppel et j'avais déjà
des affinités avec eux quand on se
croisait lors des compétitions j'avais
pu passer quelques fois là bas pour voir
que ce n'était pas qu'une réputation et
a tout de suite quand je suis passé
professionnel je me suis dit qu'il
fallait aller chez eux croient que nous
la route maintenant je suis ivre noise
vous êtes yvelinoise et vous avez un
parcours très atypique assez
exceptionnel aussi on va y revenir dans
un instant alors nous en parlions samedi
vous avez conservé votre ceinture wbc
continental des légers c'est déjà la
deuxième fois que vous défendiez ce
titre acquis pour la première fois en
avril 2021 contre la bosnienne mal à
gits en octobre vous battiez la
vénézuélienne lozano et samedi vous avez
dominé aux points l'ukrainienne mais jen
qu on a le sentiment que vous n'avez
jamais été mise en difficulté sur ce
combat comment vous l'avez ressenti de
l'intérieur oui c'est vrai que j'ai
jamais été mise en difficulté à part sur
têt un aspect mental parce que là là
l'adversaire était très vicieuse quand
je dis vicieux c'est qu'il ya des
techniques de boxe qui nous permettent
d'économiser quelques secondes quand on
est fatigué elle les accrochages et elle
jouait beaucoup à ça donc ça a cassé un
peu le combat ça nous empêcher de vox et
mais pascal a senti que j'étais au
dessus techniquement
sinon tous les rounds je sentais que
j'allais gagner j'ai jamais eu de doutes
par rapport à ça c'était juste un peu
fatigant de se pousser à chaque fois
plutôt que de boxer mais vous étiez
blessé à la main il me semble à
l'entraînement c'est ça et c'est tout le
bras qui est blessé rejet bonne
tendinite que je traîne depuis trois
semaines
donc c'était mon inquiétude mais j'ai eu
des petites douleurs lors du combat il
était tellement intense que ça me
sortait de la tête vous est donc battu
cette ukrainienne medvedko au point ce
qui porte votre total maintenant à cette
victoire une avant la limite zéro
défaite vous êtes en pleine confiance
aujourd'hui oui
j'avais besoin de ça pour me dire que
j'étais sur le bon chemin effectivement
je pense que je suis la bonne équipe et
les bonnes méthodes d'entraînement tout
va bien et on le disait un parcours
atypique vous avez 32 ans et vous avez
débuté la boxe à seulement 26 ans en
2016 en plus sans être sportive une
sportive dans l'âme alors pour vous
connaître un peu plus je renvoie les
téléspectateurs à l'émission vais y paie
qui vous était consacrée en décembre
dernier votre parcours opl digne on peut
le dire et est digne d'un scénario
hollywoodien vous avez été championne de
france très rapidement décembre 2020 et
et vous avez donc cette ceinture wba
continental quand vous avez démarré la
boxe est ce que vous vous attendiez
appareils parcours est aussi rapide
finalement ce que vous avez commencé en
2016 je le rappelle
j'ai envie de vous dire oui non oui
parce que je suis tellement acharné dans
ce que je fais que je savais que ça
allait fonctionner la salle à être
convaincu ça marcherait et c'est vrai
que je suis encore aussi surprise que ça
soit allé aussi vite donc je savais que
je deviendrais championne mais c'est
vrai que je pensais pas que mes mes
efforts père est aussi rapidement et là
aujourd'hui d'avoir ce titre là en si
peu de temps je suis moi même étonné la
recette du succès c'est le travail la
motivation voix sinon c'est la
persévérance parce que le travail tout
le monde travaille mais enfin tout ne
peut travailler mais si on lâche les
bras d'excès dure à peu pas ça peut pas
le faire dans sport de haut niveau c'est
plutôt la persévérance qu'il ya beaucoup
de deux montagnes de dentiste dans
émotionnel et il faut savoir les passer
mais vos prochains objectifs avant
peut-être de rêver d'une ceinture
mondiale la très prochainement c'est une
ceinture européenne c'est ça oui c'est
une ceinture européenne
qu'on aimerait organiser en juin
toujours aux mureaux on est très attaché
à organiser dans les yvelines ça permet
à nos partenaires de pouvoir venir nous
voir et profiter de la soirée et
j'espère que ça se fera mais vous avez
déjà une idée de l'adversaire que vous
pourriez affronter je crois que la
ceinture est vacante en plus cette
semaine je n'ai aucune idée ça c'est mon
entraîneur qui gère ça d'accord or vous
savez je regarde jamais jamais mes
adversaires je les découvre le jour du
combat une dernière question sur
l'aspect sportif est ce que vous avez
les les jeux olympiques aussi de 2024
qui vont se dérouler à paris ce que vous
vous l'avez dans un dans un coin de
votre tête à bac + 4/5 ans de mac
attente c'est le seul objectif qui est
fixé et on va tout faire pour être sûr
paris 2024 dès la rentrée je réintègre
pleinement les guides de france pour
faire un maximum de stages et de
compétition pour retrouver l'essentiel
de la boxe olympique qui n'est pas la
même et c'est clairement dans l'ambition
de participer au jeu une toute dernière
question parce qu'en plus d'être une
sportive vous êtes aussi engagés sur le
terrain associatif depuis juillet 2021
vous avez créé l'association premier
round qui est voilà je cite l'article de
poissy qui vous avez été consacrée sur
le sujet s'est attrapé le public
décrocher et le ramener vers le terrain
professionnel grâce à la rigueur l
estime de soi qu'apporte le sport
pourquoi vous engagez justement dans ce
nouveau combat parce que c'est un autre
combat
c'est parce que quand j'ai découvert le
sport à l'époque moi même j'ai été
décroché dans le sens où j'avais pas
confiance en moi dans le sens où je
faisais que des petits boulots j'avais
beaucoup de kilos en plus j'en avais pas
et dès que j'ai fait la rencontre du
sport toute ma vie a changé petit à
petit grâce au sport et donc j'ai envie
de partager cette expérience auprès de
toutes ces personnes qui sont plus
classés un petit peu aller et j'ai envie
de leur faire découvrir cette sensation
de bonheur et de doit avoir envie de
prendre soin soit est logiquement ce qui
va en découler celle en d2 de se
débrouiller puis aussi de se réintégrer
en fait le sport aujourd'hui c'est un
outil social
merci rim ayadi d'avoir été avec nous et
on suivra bien sûr vos prochaines
échéances avec grande attention merci
également à miquel et demi d'euros
journalistes aux sports de la rédaction
de télé 78
merci à vous voilà c'est la fin de ce
journal merci de votre fidélité dans un
instant vous retrouver mélanie poké son
émission 7 8 sociétés sur tv 78 belle
soirée à tous
[Musique]